all right let's go back to the phones at
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 we will talk to our
caller from the to15 area code 2 1 5
what's your name are you calling from hi
David this is Jerry from Philadelphia
hey how are you I'm good how are you
good
so my question isn't about impeachment
but it's a little bit more about
education all right so a few weeks ago I
think you had a caller calling about you
know how he thinks prereqs and
humanitarian classes maybe should be
eliminated and I agree that I think we
do need them as a society to better
understand each other and be more
empathetic as the previous caller had
alluded my question is what are your
thoughts on the fact that everything is
becoming like doctoral prepared so I
think that that's like contributing to
the loan crisis it's like a physical
therapist and occupational therapist has
to now go back and be a doctor it's like
do you think that that is something that
we should be striving towards like I
don't I'm not aware of that so but
you're saying that occupational
therapists have to be doctors now I've
just I'm just not familiar enough with
what you're saying yes so in the medical
field so I'm a nurse and I'm getting I'm
currently in my final year I'm going to
be a nurse practitioner next year and
I'm getting my masters but the big push
is that they want me to get my DNP
instead of my msn so it would be that I
would be a doctorate of Nursing Practice
versus just having my masters which my
scope of practice does not change
regardless of me having either
credential it's the same for
occupational therapy physical therapists
speech therapists they all now have to
get doctorate of practice in their
respective field so I hate to be this
cynical but does that allow a higher
reimbursement rate from insurance like
his mum or my money mine goes is this
about money more than anything else that
is a great question I do not know the
question in terms of reimbursement from
a nursing standpoint some it's state
driven so like in Pennsylvania I can
practice
independently but I still need a doctor
to oversee um you know my practice yeah
but I don't necessarily know
practitioners as a whole are reimbursed
at say eighty seven percent I don't know
the exact numbers eighty seven percent
versus a doctor ninety-five percent sure
based on insurance companies and I'm
almost certain that it doesn't matter if
you have your DMP versus your MSM okay I
mean listen I don't know enough about it
to say too much more but when I hear
about a push for a more involved degree
in order to see patients where my mind
goes is that probably is more profitable
for the place you're working at gotcha
yes that is true and do you think that
it's also related to colleges wanting to
make more money by forcing us to always
get more more degrees uh I mean listen
the incentive is certainly there I just
I don't want to copy it sounds
reasonable I just don't want to say for
sure cuz I'm just not familiar enough
with the specifics of what you're asking
about but it certainly would not
surprise me that that's the case okay
perfect
thank you so much for your time I
appreciate it alright I appreciate the
call thank you so much